bom dia
a antes mas posso explicar me dizer bom
dia de volta só por eu ter esse carinho
do uol campo bom dia
isso é muito para quem precisa um bom
dia sem mais enérgico mania o bom dia
então eu fui convidada para falar sobre
um tema que me é muito caro a
criatividade é eu faço parte do grupo
soico trabalham diariamente nas
indústrias criativas ou nas chamadas
indústrias criativas em particular no
setor das artes visuais
eu sou artista plástica eu sempre quis
ser artista
aos oito anos de idade ganhou um
concurso de design de jornal notícias
o objetivo do concurso é premiar a
criança que fizesse o melhor design de
uma caravela portuguesa muito mais do
que a alegria que sente ao vencer o
concurso
lembro me da felicidade que sentia
sempre que desenhava certo modo sempre
soube que queria ser artista porque
minha forma de me expressar e quantas
histórias passava sobretudo todos ainda
era a minha forma de comunicar
de acordo com os jovens que o público
vai ganhar o autor britânico e campeão
de audiência
todas as crianças são criativas e à
medida que vão crescendo e seguindo o
seu percurso escolar vão matando essa
criatividade e ainda aqui levanta a mão
não sonhava quando era criança e agora
vamos levantar a mão quem desejava
quando era criança
nós vamos deixando desenhar à medida que
vamos crescendo porque nos vão ser
embutidos um conjunto de preconceitos
sobre o design sobre a nossa forma nos
preçários por isso sei que envolvem
sands igual out of creativity
esta fotografia do doutor sheldon cooper
personagem central da série a teoria do
big bang da qual eu sou uma grande fã
que representa um físico teórico está
neste documento porque o partilha várias
idéias e preconceitos com meu pai na
série o doutor xiao de culpa
o veículo uma ideia partilhada por
muitas pessoas de que existe uma
hierarquia de saber em que o chão
decisivamente mais importantes do que
outros
nesta hierarquia das ciências estão
acima das letras e por sua vez estão
muito acima das artes
existe até um episódio da série
televisiva do doutor sheldon cooper
baliza ao seu design plus disciplinas
relacionadas com as letras e história
mas artistas então são quase informadas
ora o doutor sheldon culpa é uma
personagem composta por vários elementos
que integram caricaturas da sociedade
contemporânea exista um pouco do doutor
xiao gang culpa em cada um de nós e no
meu pai com certeza quando se vê que o
grupamento seguir no ensino secundário o
meu pai não conseguia entender o porquê
de uma aluna com boas notas que poderia
escolher qualquer agrupamento escolher
justamente o agrupamento dois cursos de
artes visuais
ora acusado será dizer que passou os
três anos seguintes e tentar do governo
de ingressar numa faculdade de belas
artes e devo dizer que conseguiu em 1998
iniciei a minha licenciatura e
arquitetura economia criativa mundial é
um grande negócio
hoje em dia museus como o louvre em
paris eo teto moda no twitter no reino
unido em londres que serve milhões de
visitantes anualmente a cultura é sem
dúvida um dos mais importantes setores a
criar conteúdos para o turismo
há já muito tempo que sendo que a
economia criativa é chave para o
crescimento econômico
existe uma relação direta entre a
riqueza inovação e competitividade uma
nação ea criatividade
uma das nações mais ricas do mundo os
estados unidos é o berço de vários
ícones criativos que marcam a cultura do
século 20 ea cultura contemporânea
na primeira imagem da esquerda pra
direita vemos michael vai a madrid
estava o michael bem de mim vai é um
realizador americano conhecido por seus
filmes da ação campeões do vitória como
por exemplo os transformers war on um
artista plástica americana que se tornou
a mais importante figura associada ao
movimento artístico por parte de pois aí
a electronic arts empresa americana de
videojogos que publica os jogos campeões
como fifa uma nf é o herschel o sr
futebol etc e por último uma pessoa que
eu sou uma grande fã está no e escritor
e editor e produtor da banda desenhada e
chairman da marvel comics criou em
colaboração com vários artistas os pais
da menina o roto juntar se for o tom e
os x-men dentro das chamadas indústrias
criativas existem 11 indústrias chávez
que foram identificadas pela unesco e
pela agência de consultoria e uai
as artes visuais às artes performativas
da rádio a música os livros jornais e
revistas cinema televisão e captura
vídeos jogos e publicidade
de acordo com os dados fornecidos pela
unesco e pela agência iguais às
economias criativas da emprega cerca de
30 milhões de pessoas em todo o mundo e
geraram uma receita 2.25 triliões de
dólares em 2015 que correspondem a 3% da
riqueza mundial em 2003
este valor é substancialmente superior à
das telecomunicações globais que geraram
um ponto 85 trilhões de dólares e
significativamente maior do que o pib
índia rússia ou do canadá
chama atenção para o número 2 do qual eu
faço parte
às vezes o lattes as artes visuais é o
segundo maior no setor mas é de todos o
que gera mais emprego
agora vou fazer uma pergunta e quer que
o município não com um chute dado quem
da audiência gosta de arte contemporânea
vai do brás são bastante
eu não gosto particularmente de arte
contemporânea
o conceito por trás de uma obra de arte
de origem à criação de diversos objetos
quando o artista pop americano andrew
órgão criou uma obra com vários quadros
de constituição de impressões de uma
embalagem é lotada campeãs este conceito
de origem à criação de inúmeros objetos
comerciais utilizando esta imagem
inicialmente criada por mark campos
canecas bolsa senhora robôs ou seja o
artista perrenoud uma para a existência
cria uma obra de arte que por sua vez dá
origem a inúmeros objetos comerciais
inspirados na sobriedade
entramos num ciclo quase não sabemos qo
nasceu primeiro foi galinhas foi o outro
o artista utilizou a imagem e objeto
preexistentes e criou apenas um novo
conceito em torno deste objeto como
resultados surgem inúmeras ramificações
comerciais resultantes desta
conceptualização o que é a criatividade
este é o meu tanque sobre qualquer
atividade
suplentes idéias que outras pessoas
tiveram primário
nada de verdadeiramente original
na realidade a originalidade é
subvalorizada obra de marcel duchamp
intitulada da fonte a fonte
lotadas 1917 é mais famosas do artista e
inventor dos animais obra original está
perdido até a data de hoje
esta continua urinol organizado
produzido industrialmente assinada e
datada de 1917 em 1964 o taiti mandou
produzir uma réplica em cerâmica
artesanal vidrada o mais próximo
possível da obra original
esta é a versão da obra que tem sido
exposta até hoje o artista marcelo chama
estreou conceito de que qualquer objeto
pode ser arte desde que seja assinado
por um artista como resultado a arte
deixou de ser um sistema onde o mérito e
excelência de um terminado com o site da
sua execução são valorizados como
artista eu gostava de ter o cruzeiro o
oposto do xampu
eu gostava de tirar a classificação de
obra data determinados objetos
eu acredito que o caminho para atingir o
mérito passa pela criatividade e pelo
trabalho árduo isso havia passado antes
de uma conversa que entre vários
artistas o do corte indiana do chang e
haydn em que eles falam um pouco suja
idéia de criar a obra da cantão e outra
coisa interessante é que a nossa
história obviamente eo gênero as
questões do gênero a ser uma artista
mulher traz uma grande vantagem traz uma
vantagem histórica porque existe todo um
conjunto de artistas homens consagrados
em muito poucas mulheres têm a ver com a
nossa história e traz uma desvantagem
mesmo na atualidade porque resultados à
sociedade que nós próprios criamos a
maior parte milionários do mundo são
homens que são os compradores de arte
contemporânea e artes em geral
importantes são público mais interessado
muitas vezes em obra criada por outros
homens
então eu precisar as a minha
criatividade
então comecei a trabalhar portugal teve
uma ditadura até muito tarde e terminou
com 25 de abril de 1974 a nossa cultura
popular é afetada por ventos políticos e
como resultado os objetos mais
representativos da cultura popular
portuguesa são distintos daqueles que se
encontravam na mesma época nos países
europeus ou até mesmo nos estados unidos
o primeiro objeto simbólico da cultura
popular portuguesa que utilizarem em
várias obras da minha autoria foi o
adufe quando as suas audiências e sabem
o que é um erro
há muito o do fornecimento opção
português que tem origem no darfur um
instrumento ara eu comecei em 2010 a
retratar as pessoas do interior do país
a entrevistar várias pessoas e assistir
aos ensaios das adufeiras eu achava mais
interessante ir aos ensaios do que as
suas apresentações públicas porque nos
ensaios com você estava em suas
conversões em letras a fazer mal mas
outro canal o dolphin e contam histórias
e eu queria captar essa realidade e
perceber a importância porque continua a
acontecer em determinados lugares estes
encontros de pessoas em torno de um
objeto que agrega que a uff resultado
criei a minha primeira grande instalação
de arte contemporânea
composta por vários dedos pintados à mão
por mim na altura de crise é muito
criativa porque não tinha muito dinheiro
para produzir a obra então fui pedir a
cada um dos artesãos produzido o filme
usava uma dúvida quando foi caro e eu
não tinha dinheiro para produzir uma
obra tão grande e portanto fluir e cada
artesão da zona da raia ofereceu uma do
futuro que depois foi pintado e as fitas
foram traçadas as fitas de seda foram
todas atrasadas e ferramenta gigante um
objeto simbólico
eu lembrei que há maior noção do
conforto que eu tinha na minha infância
quando a minha mãe me aconselhava na
cama e então a idéia de ser uma meta é
até que nos cobra um símbolo da
maternidade da mulher eo filho porque
quando as ofertas estão ensaiar e tocar
o adufe chamou a atenção dos homens
batendo as mãos dizem isso não é produto
carlos porque é um instrumento da mulher
no caixa
hoje há homens que toca a duff mas
tradicionalmente é um instrumento ligado
ao universo feminino que faz parte
daquilo que é a nossa história então eu
peguei os nossos ícones populares e
comecei a criar instalações com eles
esta esteve no mudo anterior no museu do
design e da moda em 2013 e esta é que
esteve na catedral de manchester em 2014
esta obra esteve patente uma exposição
chamada mulheres do meu país
foi uma exposição que eu produzir com
inúmeras mulheres emigrantes portuguesas
em manchester há então eu tenho aquele e
no hope mil perto do órgão importa em
manchester e as senhoras todos os dias
ao fim de 12 anos fiz mas não venham
ajudar com a tui e em transar fitas de
cetim a colocar contas em claros para
decorar as obras da arte e foi desde
algo que mexeu esta exposição que foi a
primeira exposição do artista plástica
contemporânea na catedral de manchester
tanto que é muito complicado fazer um
bispo e um de e todas as pessoas que
estão por trás da organização desta
natureza aceitarem uma exposição desta
escala numa catedral
esse foi um processo muito muito
importante pra mim e chamou-os mulheres
do meu país precisamente por isso porque
construir com as mulheres do meu país da
minha origem indo buscar a província é
que eu pintei os adultos a quase como se
fosse um astro tarde com um consenso com
várias cores com sobreposição e
trabalhar em uma peça gigante que inclui
63 a dulce que tem sete metros por 10
esta é outra das obras que esteve na
catedral que é composta por dez mil
flores de papel que são as forças
utilizadas na nossa cultura popular nas
festas tradicionais a decorar as ruas a
decorar as praças mais uma vez em
momentos que são centrais da nossa
cultura popular vão para uma instalação
e vão contar uma nova história com tempo
vanessa portugal dentro de uma catedral
e técnica ao centro está um croqui fazia
parte de uma posição é uma crônica um
metro de diâmetro gigante e que está a
coroar o povo as pessoas a entrada dessa
catedral é que outra das obras que
esteve patente nesta exposição lightman
que todas as cias
as piadas de de contas do cristal foram
trabalhadas por mim com os imigrantes
portugueses no atelier da obra todo em
ferro metal e vidro
outra versão branca da mesma obra
resultados desta exposição
esta exposição foi a expressão mais
visitada de sempre na cidade que é mais
200 mil visitantes de julho e setembro
de 2014 e como resultado da catedral de
manchester que tem uma importante
coleção de arte que inclui artistas
franceses e italianos convidam a
produzir uma obra do corinthians
permanente para integrar a coleção da
catedral na altura pensar como vou
contar uma nova história que vai ficar
gravada na catedral para sempre e que
vai contar um pouco daquilo que é a
minha origem e daquilo que é este meu
destino que também faz parte de mim
agora então percebi que em 1957 a rainha
de inglaterra isabel segunda tinha
visitado a primária que é a vez de
portugal
ele foi oferecida uma bolsa em bordado
de castelo branco
comecei então a estudar um pouco sobre o
bordado de castelo branco bordado de
castelo branco é uma técnica que surgiu
no século 17 que vai evoluindo no século
19 não ficas travou filha da forma como
é executada hoje é um bordado e fui que
faz parte do nosso período sempre alvo
em as influências temáticas bem do nosso
povo sempre a nossa presença na índia e
no sul da china e este marcas centrais
estão árvore da vida e vários outros e
um médico que se associou ao mar a
agitação e então produzindo essa idéia é
criar um marco da vida contemporânea e
crianças 7 peça gigante símbolo da
castello branco com três metros de
largura as maiores que vão cobrir todos
os altares da catedral de manchester ao
mesmo tempo
esta é uma delas as peças estão em
produção e vão ficar concluídas para
inaugurar este tempo a 17 setembro deste
ano na catedral de manchester
então esta é uma das peças com os
monstros aqui quase em exclusivo que não
é por serão que são as que compõem o
jardim do éden
são quatro árvores da vida assim como a
árvore tradicional que faz a guarda na
coxa castelo branco uma interpretação
contemporânea em que temos primária
primavera o verão o outono eo inverno
obrigada a terminar minha apresentação
acho que tenho aqui um time só por
tantas coisas para não ter passado muito
tempo
espero que tenham gostado se quiserem
conhecer mais sobre o meu trabalho as
posições têm o show nívea eo website
obrigada
[Aplausos]